taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hey taste buddies it's a taste bud show
my name is joe
my name is sam oh you're in a good mood
uh yeah i guess so okay i guess so i
want you to be i always want you yeah i
want you to be
let's get something straight with the
listeners outside of this when when this
stops when we hit stop on the recording
thing we don't speak for weeks
i was going to say the opposite no i
know i was going to say like i jump on
your
shoulders and we're a team in a chicken
fight yeah we have a guy on the same
side right after this sal and i have a
lot of laughs together a lot of people
wonder no actually nobody wonders this
i've never been asked
but sometimes i think we we worry that
the folks at home
think um that we have a real tension
between us
yeah we don't we just we do in that
moment for damn sure
yeah that's real but yeah but it ends
there it is
yeah i'm not i'm not harboring
resentment i'm not i'm not
walking away from this thinking any less
of you for all your terrible takes no
never never
bill burr bill burke called me the other
day laughing and he goes
jesus christ joe you guys are yelling
like it's
like you're getting to like political
argument energy
i mean he loves the show i i love
how much burr loves the show he's like
the best we i mean let's get him on the
goddamn thing already
so let's get him on i would love to come
on yeah together to get him on and
because he gets he can get he gets just
as passionate about
sam morell loves the show i love him
high praise the other night
we should eventually open it up it's
just it's really this the
pandemics are keeping us from having
guests because we have to get
tested every time yeah we're gonna get
moving and then i also
and i left you a message about this the
greatest compliment we will ever get
we are never going to top this it
doesn't matter if if
the president himself or the pope came
and said i love the
show there will never be a higher
compliment to this keith robinson
said to me whoa he goes she goes he
hates god
damn it i love your show and i hate it
i hate that i love it
i want to trash your dumb show but it
makes me laugh every time i love it
right keith said that yeah tough critic
tough critic
i was like i said to him i go jesus
keith that really means a lot
man thank you like i was like you that's
because trust me
the man would like nothing more yeah i
understand that stinks
i know keith likes me too but if i ask
him he's like you're all right
well i can i know he likes me well keith
god bless you i said on the previous
episode one of the previous episodes
that you were puerto rican wrapped up in
an italian
yeah that came from me and keith talking
about you yeah we
[Laughter]
we were we and keith agreed that we
didn't like that you were trying to
pose as an italian and we were calling
you undercover puerto rico
i'm just as much of each well no
actually i'm more italian because my
half of my spanish half
is puerto rican and actual spanish and a
little bit of cuban
i think that's my grandpa born in cuba
um very spicy which brings me
to today's debate well can we just say
shout out to the taste buddies because
we got oh yes cat and snickers
from the last episode or the kitkat
snickers episode
we got it trending um i i i
i saw it at number seven in the united
states
it caught fire they included our poll
and then everyone at large on the
internet i guess you started to
have the debate and uh we're still
seeing how that has filtered back to us
last week hundreds of thousands of votes
on snickers
wild man wild stuff wild stuff
and as our way as our as one of the ways
that we want to say thank you
yes today's episode is based on fan
suggestion
yes uh if you apologize in advance that
we don't remember
who suggested this but it was suggest
there was a lot of suggestions came in
i'm that that's a faux pas i'm sorry but
anyway this was suggested by one of the
fans
we got emails to the to our gmail email
and
a lot of people had cheesesteak for
something else chicken parm or something
else
and then so and then someone had it
against each other and we're like
because you're a philly guy
yeah and so you're going to rep that
cheesesteak hard i'm going to wrap that
cheese stick harder and i'm you know
i'm born and raised here in new york and
you know what i mean
yeah it's max max yeah you know what
that means i have kids say that
uh sl you start trying to say it slash
that's what i mentioned oh
holy [ __ ] louise
joe derosa tick-tock star okay boomer
i hate that i can't i hated that too
because also we're not that generation i
know but it's like millennials aren't
it's gen z now too it's not even
millennials no it's just it's stupid
anyway yo i am from new york born and
raised
and there's two things three things is
the bodega the bagel store
and the pizzeria that's what we have a
lot of and so as far as the pizzeria
goes
the sandwich i i would think the king
sandwich from pizzeria you might like
meatball palm you might like an eggplant
bar you might like a
sausage and peppers but we're going to
go with chicken parm hero for
everyone's number one pizzeria sandwich
so you're putting up your philly
cheesesteak
against the chicken hero now here's the
thing
you'll find plenty of chicken parm
heroes in it or well we'll call them
uh chicken park it's funny in philly
a hoagie means cold right right
but we call our subs hoagies sure so you
would you wouldn't even call
the chicken you wouldn't even call it
chicken parmesan
you would call it a chicken parm
sandwich i don't even call it a sub you
know
i don't call it we don't call it a subs
here if i if i'm going to say the word
sub i'm referencing a cold cut
as well i'll take it from but we say
hero it's hero
we you wouldn't say hero in philly
either okay you just called it it would
say hot sandwiches called sandwiches
and that would be like turkey hokey
whatever and then the other side would
say chicken parm veal parm whatever
question yeah what is the uh etymology
of
of the hero bread why is it called hero
uh i think also why is it called hoagie
i'm going to take a guess
with hero that hero is because it's like
when you do a hero shot
in a movie it just means big it's big
it's like you're making something it's
grand you know
head over to new york city hold on a
second here i finally got my goddamn
glasses
the term likely comes from new york
herald tribune columnist clementine
paddleworth that's a hell of a name who
in 1936 described a sandwich so large
you had to be a hero to eat it yeah so
big you know like
wow more so than a sub a hero can refer
to both
sub obviously submarine yeah yeah
because it's shaped like a submarine
what about a hoagie
a hoagie is a submarine sandwich but why
they originally called
hoggies before the name hoagie took hold
why italian immigrants were i don't know
italian immigrants who worked at the hog
island shipyard began making sandwiches
wow called hoggies for that reason oh so
so the hoagie the word hoagie was born
out of philly
wow the only place i've ever seen it
called a hoagie like
like but that has gone on to be people
call them
but i've seen the word hoagie elsewhere
obviously but i'm telling
like philly it is like you you can't
find a person to say suburb hero in
philly it just doesn't
what's that it's not a word who says
grinder
grinders and grinders
what's the difference between a sub and
a hoagie with a sub the bread is salt is
a softer roll cut
all the way through and the top is
separated from the bottom
with a hoagie the harder roll is
preferred and the roll is split and the
contents
are stuffed into the roll and folded
closed
oh i see so you're splitting it but it's
going into that's very and that's very
true because in new york
if you get a sub right yeah they always
cut the bread
i didn't realize that also at subway
when subway first started they would cut
the they would cut like a weird
shape out of the top and lift it out and
then put the meat in
uh uh hoagie always cut with the v-shape
hey
you cut the crease into the and keep the
roll in the v with a crease on it
like a greeting card which is what we
did at joey rose's i was very adamant
about that i was like
every sandwich has to be v-cut ah and
that helps keep everything together
is that what it does it's just a
different approach it just it does
change the dynamic of it i can't the
bites are
i couldn't explain to you why yeah but
but it does change the dynamics
you're saying a grinder is a
hot hoogie a grinder's a hot hoagie yeah
it's a grinders like hot
it's a hot sandwich what is a grinder a
common term in new england is grinder
but it's
origin its origin has several
possibilities one theory is the name
coming from italian american slang for
dock worker among whom the sandwich was
popular
again it goes back to the docks call it
a grinder because the bread requires
much
chewing i don't i just don't i guess
you're grinding okay so it's just
another
it's coming out of new england they call
it a grinder we call it a hero
you call it a haggy it's fun to say that
by the way i've never said it that way
but it's way more fun hoagie is not as
fun as hey
i've never seen a grinder that wasn't
hot but
it sounds like they can be called the
origin of hoagies
grinders subs heroes we've all covered
the next thing is a word i've never
heard of in my life in reference to a
sandwich
and spuckies a what spucky
s-p-u-c-k-i-e-s okay now i've never
heard that word in my life
and it's on there it's the fifth name
for a hero we've heard all the other
names god almighty pimp once again
pimp did you see what he typed i didn't
pimp stop for a second
don't click see what he typed
yeah what's a sparky he didn't even make
it
singular what's a spucky yeah
what's a spuckies
some bostonians still call a sub or a
hero the nickname comes from
spookadela spuckadella
a local bakery version of a sandwich
roll so this is a melted one this cheese
melts roll crisp salad melts with the
meat
so this is a hot sandwich does it strike
you as peculiar that you've heard the
other four terms for sandwich
a million times over in your life and
this was included with those and i've
never
even seen the word spucky in print yeah
it's so weird that boston would hang on
to something that the rest of the
country has progressed past
it's not like boston oh is that a suit
they're saying it's spooky
can you can you hit me with one of those
pronunciation things
meaning it means long row spookadela
means wrong long road so maybe it's a
spooky
spooky spooky is funnier it's more fun
than spunky but look at that there's a
place called spookies and pizza
how to pronounce spooky spucky let's
hear it it's here
that is [ __ ] so spuckadella is a long
roll it said that's why it's called that
all right well our battle today
the two spuckies that are against one
another
the almighty cheesesteak versus a
i love a chicken parm sandwich don't get
me wrong i love a cheese stick
but have you ever had a real cheesesteak
i have yeah i've i've lived a long life
i've traveled
i i've had the the the ones in philly
that everyone
and then the ones off the beaten path
and and you can get a good
that whole thing where it's like go to
the city where it's from get yourself a
lobster roll from here a cheesesteak
from here
a blah blah blue from there by the way
we live in a world now where
chefs migrate and you could still bake i
got news for you
i can have a cheese steak in new york
that is as good as a cheese steak in
philly
i get the whole i'm hard-pressed to find
it i get the hullabaloo
like you're reading the car and go to
philly we're getting cheesesteaks the
reason you could get a good cheesesteak
in new york is because you're getting it
from a guy from philly
who opens the cheese take place in new
york you can't do that
you're coming out of the gate with a
logical uh uh logical argument you think
you think there's a you think there's
they're just called phillies or
or you know uh 99 miles from philly or
whatever do you think they're just
called that for no reason
no i think they're trying to capitalize
on the authenticity of the origins
in los angeles there were there were
five or six really
great authentic cheesesteak places every
one of the guys that are the
proprietor was from philly or from south
jersey i appreciate the fact that you
did a lit
litmus test with five businesses in the
los angeles greater
metro area but i would venture to say
tell me where anytime a place says it
has an authentic cheesecake it doesn't
mean that the guy
uprooted this no i'm telling i would
talk to them because i was so homesick
and i was talking about the fact that
you discussed with an
owner that was in la that he was from
philadelphia
i have issue with the fact that you said
if you ever
get a good cheesesteak in new york and
it's authentic it's probably most likely
because the guy
drove here from philly and then and
started living here is anything
possible yes but there is a there are
there there's
nuance the devil's in the details as
they say okay
and there's stuff in the little nooks
and crannies of the cheesesteak that
make it a good cheesesteak
for instance some places don't know
that you need to mix the cheese into the
meat a certain way
some places don't know to use a certain
type of cheese some places don't
understand why a certain type of cheese
doesn't work
some places don't get why it doesn't
need a dressing some places don't
get why it shouldn't have big thick cut
bell peppers all over it
all of these things all of these things
the type of meat you're using
the type of roll you're putting it on
how the meat is seasoned
all of these things play into what makes
a great
philly cheesesteak i
love what you just said because it was
going to be part of my
own argument against the cheesesteak
which is clearly
that the cheese steak is a heart it's an
easier sandwich to mess up
and if i take all the cheesesteaks i've
ever had
and all the chicken parms they've ever
had i got like a 50 50 shot when i order
a cheesesteak
that they're gonna do it and do it and
do me right okay
i'll tell you because of all those
reasons i've gotten just like this
cheese on top of the sandwich
i've gotten way too much pepper way too
much onion but we're not talking about
the bad versions we're talking about the
good versions i mean you want to talk
bad versions of food
chicken parm sandwich half the time and
you know this as well as i do
it is not a cutlet made from scratch it
is not made with any love
it came in a big frozen pack of cisco
chicken cutlets that they throw into a
deep fire then they throw it onto a roll
with some kind of generic sauce and a
melted cheese
the entire thing turns into bread mush
by the by halfway through it
okay you know i guess we won't talk
about the bad sandwiches then but
no but let's talk good versus good [ __ ]
no no that's no problem
but i'm piggybacking on what you said
because you you the guy from philly
who said that i might not have even had
a real one who goes and talks to
cheesesteak shop owners to see where
they come from i go and i sit down with
them your first
big breath of of a statement was
how this one doesn't know how to do this
that and you didn't even stop it went on
for like 10 things and you named every
item they don't know how to do the
cheese they don't know how to do the
peppers they don't know about the meat
and i've and everyone cause you were
making a claim that it was just so easy
to make a cheese stick and anybody could
do it
and you could walk away when did i say
that you know you're going you're going
you know i've had goats
we've been recording the world we've
been recording this argument for three
minutes when did i say that it was very
easy
you came right out did you have traveled
the world i get cheese sticks all over
the place it doesn't matter where you go
you just said that i said that the
cheesesteak is very simple to make
i said it's the easier food to mess up
meaning that it's harder to make no no
no
what i see what i'm talking about is
when you were talking about when you
would gallivan
around the world and you could just get
a cheesesteak anywhere
because i'm just i i said there was no
big deal i didn't say
just cheesesteak i said lobster roll
from here cheese date romeo and blah
blah blah from there
i don't like when people like you you
haven't had a cheesesteak if you didn't
go to philly i'm like
dude i agree that's annoying but that's
all i said fine
no but you did say you go you go i've
had plenty of great cheesesteaks in new
york and i said the reason you've had
plenty of great cheat sheets in new york
is because you're getting them from a
guy who's from philly that is not true
that was my point how can you make you
know
you know how i would describe you you
know how i would describe you to people
who don't know you
if i had to like just distill your
essence down
you know what it's not a bad take it's
going to be a word it's going to be a
good it's going to be a word that can be
both taken in different
positive and negative ways i would say
joe derosa is
bold oh okay you're bold because you
make really bold claims oh yeah yeah
well that you you
so you're staring at me right here
you're looking at me you're a foot away
you have all your wits about you right
right
do you think that any time i have a
cheese steak in new york that's good
it's because the guy who made it from
i think that you are exaggerating about
how many good cheesesteaks you've had
about in new york
first of all and second of all i am
saying there's a difference between
a good and edible cheesesteak that you
get from a corner deli which is fine
which is good
and you're happy whatever and a true
kick-ass philly cheesesteak
okay i'm just talking about a good
cheesesteak
from the deli look look i could go i
could go have you has anyone that's not
italian made you a decent chicken farm
hero ever
yeah sure but my point is this my point
is this is like i could go to a bodega
for instance right
yeah and i could get an italian sub i
could i could put the meats together
it's you know and i go i'm happy yeah
it's a good show
but when you get a real italian
hoagie like our true deal like you go to
a real italian show
you get the right so let's put those two
sandwiches up against you yeah
that's no problem let's argue let's do
what we let's let's just take the best
of the best here
so i i could pick a like a a real nice
brooklyn pizzeria
and what their chicken parm here is like
and you could pick a a staple in philly
james steak south street well there you
go jim
jim's yeah jims you familiar with the
name no i'm just asking
hey hey man you're in the fight mood
today huh you're in a fighting mood
today
you bugged me i i i i i was asking
to re-hear the name of the place that we
wanted to plug you said
i wanted to make it mental
you said it a little flipping a little
stutter when he said jim's because i was
like wait was it jim
you said it a little flippantly
flippingly there was a little tone
you are not reading the room my friend i
was not being like gyms
was it jim's that's not what i was doing
i was like jim
tell me why a chicken parm shop oh you
want to go today
yeah i do want to go today i do want to
go today and you come in here with a
pittsburgh hat on
just to rub another pennsylvania city in
my face yeah
you think this is the city i know what
you're doing this is the city when
you're talking pennsylvania
it's right here and i love philly i
really do shout out to philly
but pittsburgh is my jam when it comes
to pennsylvania
i'm sorry i don't know what you want to
tell you i'll tell you what my gm
i think it's the best sports town in the
world long island
the best of all new york islands that's
my jam
how about that you like that because we
can both play this game
you're one of the people who are
comparing long island to staten island
i'm asking you a question tell me why a
chicken parm sandwich is better than a
cheese okay but
tell it to me all right i know you're
prompting me for this but let me
let me go take it from where you left
off you the person from philly the
self-proclaimed
like yep like i mean you have a
doctorate in cheesesteaks right
the first thing that you decided to do
was list the 10 to 10 ways
that people mess up cheesesteaks all the
time
i didn't say all the time i ordered a
cheesesteak from a place that i really
trust here
and they came with these really tough
beef tips in it
that's terrible another another place
put slices of cheese on top not
mixed in to the whole entire thing you
got places that use real estate yeah
please
do you like steakhums that's a sacrilege
i don't hate them what about cheese whiz
on there uh i prefer
white american cheese on a steak okay
and then i put cheese whiz on the fries
okay i find that in a cheese steak a lot
of times you got to get
grease control in order i feel like a
lot of times with a cheesesteak
if they don't do it the right way you're
getting a sopping wet uh hoagie full of
grease
absolutely all right i feel like a lot
of times i think you said that they
should put
large chunks of green pepper in there
bell pepper i
feel like i said no i said they
shouldn't oh okay i one of my biggest
complaints
with a cheesesteak is that they just
they basically quarter
a bell pepper and throw it in the
goddamn spices terrible
and sometimes they just go overboard on
the onions
like it's ratio is really important
keeping the grease down is important
mixing that cheese in is important
i agree uh if you're not having it right
away and that thing's getting wrapped it
doesn't travel well with cheesecake
no no no no it's looking like a wet
noodle
i eat cold cheesesteaks all the time no
not cold not cold
it does travel well it does it's hot and
it's wrapped it travels fine no
no look i open that thing up it's just
nosy and greasy sandwich if you don't
put it in the fridge for a while
because you're not going to eat it
immediately travels well that's not fair
that's not fair okay but i'll say this
you know how many chicken parm subs i've
had
do you know how many you want to talk
about a food easy to screw up
do you know how many chicken parm subs
i've had my ingredients do you know how
many chicken that's not the batter four
cheese take two ingredients no uh it's
steak
cheese peppers no it's not pepperoni
that's not saying it's not peppers
you just count bread as an ingredient i
mean the five elements
this mic off your fart i just said
chicken parm had three and i said end
bread so i just included the bread
yo bro what's wrong with you today man
cheese steak you got something on your
mind you want to talk about cheese steak
cheese steak coming at me hard cheese
steak traditionally you know we had a
couple of nice
episodes in a row where we didn't get
mad you want to you want to poke the
bear
joe you've heard of the fork the fork
you've heard of the knife
the knife you've heard of the spoon i
love the spoon
arguably my favorite what if the spoon
was magic
i thought the spoon already was magic
yeah okay
it's helping me get cereal into my mouth
that's right but i have a feeling you
have something more to say
well you know our listeners already know
where we're going because magic spoon's
been with us for a while and we're
moving boxes we're moving products here
okay that's why they keep coming back we
love them they love us and the world
spins around and around
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein which
tell me another cereal where you're
getting that kind of protein you're
making gains
while you're eating cereal right only
four net carbs in each serving so that's
keto friendly how about gluten nope
gluten free how about green
sorry charlie grain free how about soy
don't you dare soy free
a lot of carbs no low carbs what about
gmo everybody wants a gmo no you don't
because it's gmo free it's gmo free and
i gotta tell you i have no idea what gmo
is but it's not in there and i know
that's a good thing and you're not
paying for it
so look here's the greatest part they
got a new flavor
i'm very excited about this birthday
cake flavor i love
birthday cake flavor things i love
birthday cake funfetti cake is oh my god
are you nuts yeah
how about getting a birthday how about
it's your birthday and you have birthday
cake cereal that morning
why are you waiting for the cake at
night that's right start the day that's
right you start celebrating when you
rise and shine and i'll tell you what
they got
magic spoon has birthday cake uh packs
available it's a special five pack it's
limited
it's available for a limited time only i
say this to you go get yourself a five
pack of birthday cake magic spoon
give a box of it away to your closest
friends and family on their birthday
what a nice present oh that is actually
a good idea yeah you can also build your
own box
make the flavors that you want uh to
pick the flavors you want they got cocoa
they got fruity they got frosted they
got peanut butter and if you're in
canada
it's available to you too as well right
now so go to magicspoon.com
taste buds to grab the new limited
edition birthday cake or a custom bundle
of your own
choosing today you're going to use promo
code taste buds when you get there
you're gonna get five dollars off
your first order that's magicspoon.com
taste buds
and use the promo code tastebuds to get
five bucks off
this is your way to deliciously
healthy serial foe
and i just want to piggyback on what you
said you damn straight
you give someone a box of cereal for
their birthday they're going to be
thrilled
so i know a lot of us like to indulge
but a lot of us also like to get our
lives back on track and and try to
try to live in in a somewhat healthy way
right you know a balanced way i should
say yeah
and it's very hard to do what are you
getting at noom
how'd you know because i know what
noom's all about all right i was going
to do a little more of a lead-in but you
know what you're right let's just get
now because actually
get to the good thing these people are
doing it new our good friend chris uses
noom swizz bite all the time and i'm
about to start using it too because i
i want to take my my weight and my
healthy eating more seriously it's not
about what you just ate with noon but
it's how you eat in general
teaches you about eating about your
cravings about building new habits is an
app and and you can ditch your your
misconceptions and get smart about the
food choice you make you're educating
yourself that's what i like about it
is is that it's not uh you know it's not
some sort of fix all diet it's not some
sort of miracle thing it's a lifestyle
change it teaches you to recondition
yourself and to change your habits for
the better overall
and really lose weight in the effective
way yeah and you pick the health goals
that are right for you so you tailor
kind of what you're eating and then noon
personalized the weight loss program to
help your aspirations become reality so
it really is a tailored uh app that
really
you know it's unique to every person and
that's how it's different too it's not
some
it's not the same across the board well
i like that it's got many benefits it's
you know eating better to feel better
and understanding your cravings and
knowing how to shop it's uh having more
energy because you're doing this
enjoying exercise again fitting into
better clothes
it's feeling good about your choices
after all that improving
your sense of self-worth your your mood
and not being stressed
and it's easy it works with your
lifestyle you don't have to commit to
some rigorous plan
so you know i don't know i like that
it's based in psychology
and i like that it teaches you to make
the choices you do and gives you the
tool to replace your habits
with healthier ones and it takes about
10 minutes a day everyone's busy uh it
doesn't demand much of your time that's
it
80 percent of numerous finished a
program and over 60 percent
have stuck with their goals for over a
year so that's basically it you want to
deal with us is that what you want the
science to getting healthier it's good
as if this wasn't a good enough deal
already
here's what you got to do sign up for
noom through us okay a trial
starts today just go to noom n-o-o-m dot
com slash taste
bud that's n-o-o-m
dot com slash taste bud ready to learn
how to live healthy sign up for noom
today at noom.com
tastebud with or without onion
cheesesteak cheesesteak is meat and
cheese
first and foremost that's it those are
your base ingredients now if you want
onions on it if you want to make it a
pizza steak and add sauce fine you want
to add mushrooms fine but a true philly
steak
steak onion cheese served on a roll and
even the onion part of that is not true
because any philly cheesesteak place you
go to
they'd say with or without it they say
wit or without which i can't stand
yeah with or that means onions with whiz
means onions yeah no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no wait wait wait means onions without
means
witch that's what it is i'm messing it
up yeah so anyway is that right
i'm just trying to think of genos yeah
it's mean
and they go you you go up to the window
at pat's for instance which is a
touristy place yeah but you go through
the winter you say
shout out i want to go look oh you guys
i love you guys hi gino hi
shout out i i love all you guys go up to
the winners tony luke's those are all
the tourist spots right yeah
well i mean listen i love the geno
steaks i love the pat stakes
i love tony luke's um so when you i'm
just saying like those are
like some real hardcore people in philly
will go
oh come on yeah that's like i'm just
saying like i'm aware that those are the
popular spots
right but anyway my point is this
you go up to a window at a pats or a
geno's and you say i want a steak
american cheese sure whit yeah that
means with onions
without means no onions or a steak whiz
wit means you get my point my point is
this
it's a lot it's a lot do you know how
many chickens
harm sandwiches i've had that's what i
say you know how many chicken parm
sandwiches i've had yeah i gotta give
them instructions you know how many
cheeses
sauce please put the sauce you know how
many chicken okay you want to talk sauce
you made chicken parm sandwiches i've
been lacking the sauce that are bitterly
dry you know what any chicken parm
seriously i've had
you started this episode today we're
going to argue the best part
now you're complaining about bad news
bringing up the bad things about a
cheesesteak you
shaker i didn't say it was a bit i said
no what i was saying just now was
there's a lot of instructions to order a
goddamn sandwich
when i order a chicken bomb i go i'm
just telling you while we're before we
get off of it
don't make it sound like it's it's it's
impossible to scrub a chicken parm
i said that joe who said it you said it
was easier to screw up a cheesesteak
you said that i said yeah i do said it i
do think it's easier to say
i don't agree because if the sauce on
the chicken farm is bad
i had a lot of chicken parms where it
was they threw chicken fingers on a roll
with ragu
and it sucked i mean all right that's
not don't bring that here i'm just
telling you
i'm just telling you how people roll
sometimes dog
[Laughter]
something's up with you today
something's up with you today what's up
would you switch vitamins or something
no i'm trying to look in your eyes and
see what's up with you
i've had two tequilas fine oh but that's
got nothing to do with it yeah you're
one
you're two away from floor
[Music]
breakdown for me let's
sauce let's uh my
here's the thing my the ingredients of
your sandwich
can come to the ingredients of my
sandwich and become
an amazing thing you put tomato sauce
now and who is this for who is it for
i'm telling you i'm going to argue the
fact that my sauce
doesn't go good in your sandwich no no
no no what i'm saying to you is this
if you want base ingredients of my
sandwich with your sandwich which
would just be chicken breaded chicken
and cheese it wouldn't be that good
bro you are off your rocker man
italian food is i'm sorry this is i'm
also half spanish i love my second
favorite food's probably japanese food
i love all types of of foods
i think that most people would say
italian food
is who is arguing against italian food
well i'm just saying
guess what chicken parm hero is an
italian food cheesesteak's an italian
food
i got news for you i think it's an
american food it's an american italian
food though cheesesteaks are
come on why is that that's a pizza bold
here he is joey bolt
1930 the cheesesteak was invented by pat
oliveira
beca a hot dog vendor so did oliveri
also make
hot dogs into a timeline sake to pat's
king of steaks
one of my favorite cheesesteaks in all
of philadelphia you you think
you think that a cheesesteak is italian
fair are you gonna argue
you're like oh i go for somebody i'm
gonna get a cheese thing first of all
bro
yo you know what's going on here we're
watching you unravel before our eyes
you'll be coming back go into
philadelphia
you're not getting cheesesteak you don't
go to the irish pub to get cheesesteaks
you go to the pizzeria to get a
cheesesteak
it's italian gino's steaks for christ's
sakes
what are you talking about because the
two people that
that that that applied for an llc and
started my business have an italian last
name does it mean that the cheese i
think
you're making you don't file cheesesteak
on their italian foods you just don't i
don't think you don't
do nuts can we talk meat
for once for yeah for i mean let's i
mean
i'll talk meat all day long it's i love
meat i do and i love quality meat and
it's hard to find 100
grass-fed finished uh beefs it's
it's hard to find free-range organic
chicken sometimes it's hard to find
heritage breed pork
and sometimes it's really hard just to
find like wild caught salmon
at a grocery store and when you do find
them
they can be wildly no pun intended
overpriced luckily we got ourselves a
new sponsor and that sponsor goes by the
name of
butcher box i love these guys
butcherbox belize everyone deserves high
quality humanely sourced meat
and when you sign up now you get a free
essentials bundle in your first box
three pounds of chicken breast two
pounds of pork chops
and two pounds of ground beef all for
free
in your first box every month butcher
box ships a curated selection of high
quality meats
right to your home it's a no-brainer
really options like what you said
100 grass-fed and finished beef free uh
range or
not free chicken but free range organic
chicken heritage pork
they let the chickens go wherever the
chickens want to go it's free range
it's a beautiful thing wild the salmon
you got to see when we come up with a
salmon they just slap at each other
they're wild
by the way one of my favorite meats they
offer sugar-free
and nitrate-free bacon which makes bacon
okay to eat
okay it's it's the it's the nitrates and
the sugar that that ruin bacon
so anyway you're gonna go to
butcherbox.com
taste buds that's butcherbox.com
tastebuds
and you're going to get a free
essentials bundle in your first box
butcherbox.com taste buds get yourself a
free essentials bundle
included with your first bite and for a
limited time they're offering the new
members that free essentials bundle
and that's three pounds of chicken
breast two pounds of pork chop
two pounds of ground beef all for free
in your first box go to butcherbox.com
slash taste boats i gotta tell you
something right now i
i don't know if you like me but i've
been worried about internet security for
a while now
i don't like people selling my
information taking it or anything like
that like to know that when i go online
it's included secure and that's why i've
been using this
expressvpn express ppv yeah have you
heard about it yeah
yeah so you know that expressvpn is an
app that reroutes your internet
connection to your secure service so
your isp can't see the sites you visit
i see yes yeah it doesn't matter if
you're on the uh if you get your
internet from verizon or comcast joe but
uh isps in the us can legally sell your
information at companies i don't know if
you know that also
expressvpn keeps all your information
secure
it's incognito no incognito mode doesn't
even do what expressvpn does even if
you're using incognito mode they still
get reports of every website you've ever
visited
that's why expressvpn also keeps all
your information secure by encrypting
100 of the data
uh with the most powerful encryption
service so it's available on all your
devices
i don't know i don't want many people to
hear your phones or computers even your
smart tv so there's no excuse to not be
using it i've been using it now for
about four years no joke
it's really affordable but i mean okay
if we wanted to we should probably offer
something to the listeners i don't know
if you want to
i don't know if we want to tell them
about it outright if you want to get in
on it right now
i would say just protect your online
activity today with the vpn rated number
one by cnet and wired and if you want to
visit our exclusive link joe
it's expressvpn.com tastebuds
and you get three extra months free on a
one-year package
did you did you get what i was picking
up and putting down
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
tastebuds that's expressvpn.com
tastebuds to learn more if you want to
okay but let's keep it between us it's
like a hamburger i told you a hamburger
cheeseburger i got news for you buddy
go to italy you think people are eating
chicken barb sandwiches in italy they're
no
but that's not what i said joe they're
not ciao
where are you going where where where
are you
this is what you're doing you're
distracting the good people where are
you from the real
argument where are you going my move
okay you go to my moons you go i'll take
a falafel and a cheese steak
no you go to a pizzeria place to get a
cheese i go now i go anywhere
i go anywhere i go to a anywhere a diner
i go to a deli
i go to a cheesesteak restaurant i don't
say to myself i could go for italian
tonight let's get cheese steaks
[Music]
why do you bring me down this path i'm
like a blind dog italian place in philly
has cheese steaks it's
it's it's it's whatever it's italian
american family all right so so we're
battling the best italian dish is that
what we're doing no but you're talking
like you're talking as if the the
chicken parm sandwich is an italian fair
and the cheese take his
are you nuts oh cheese sticks let me
finish because i also just read that
it's about provolone onions and you said
you like yellow american oh yeah you're
a white american a white amount
any real any
oh you mean cheese whiz the italian
staple yeah
because it's so prevalent in italy to
get a sandwich that has prego
sauce dumped all over it from a jar
healthier relatively speaking than the
greasy philly cheese steak
most italian beef stands uses leaner top
brown that's roasted
look look google do me a favor girl my
name is
cheese considered italian food is it
cheesesteak considered italian food
i don't give a rat's ass there are very
many variations of a classic cheese
steak
caramelized onions seared tomatoes
italian style
philly cheesesteak uh that's not that's
doing what you just said
taking italian elements putting it in a
cheesecake just like you could say i'll
have it
that's not what i'm reading i'm saying
that the thing is like a sauce
or a pizza burger get down to me get
down to me and tell me
i'm trying explain to me how yeah
explain to me how let me tell you how
dry white meat chicken
the driest and worst of all parts of the
chicken you know what you are
breaded breaded bread you and then
dumped with sauce and cheese and then
put on more bread
is better than a steak meat sandwich
with melted cheese today you suck
bad okay today joe i'm trying to talk
oh go ahead burger king chicken parm
sandwich oh yeah cause you know italian
burger king is
what what are you talking it's like
you're spiraling out of control
not spiraling you led this argument
beyond let us talk about
the best versions of each sandwich and
you have just
inundated our ears which speak about
lackluster sandwich version i'm asking
you a question
explain to me joe cut the [ __ ]
explain the chicken palm hero has sauce
and mozzarella cheese in it
that is a staple of italian fare okay
it's a through line between most of the
most classic italian dishes cheese and
sauce red sauce marinara sauce
mozzarella that's the staple in a pizza
okay
you as a matter of fact pizza's not from
italy by the way
go ahead you got everything on a chicken
porn hero but the chicken you got the
ingredients of a pizza
a pizza is the most is the most popular
food
on this planet of earth but it really is
and you're
and that's italian you're telling me
that it's not more italian than a
cheesesteak
all i'm telling you is you're in with
the big guns now the cheese whiz
bell peppers buddy you got red sauce
and mozzarella cheese you still have a
nation
the nuts to sandwiches across the globe
let me tell you something
rattling off ingredients at the top of
your lungs
doesn't constitute why it's a better
skill three times you wouldn't ask me
why it's a better tell me why the
ingredients at the top of your lips
he was screaming ingredients at me
asking me how those ingredients
stop shaking your head ingredients stop
shaking your head yes and agreeing with
him
tell me why it's like a pet don't speak
to him that way
i'll smack your face tell me why it's a
better sandwich
joe tell me why i can't ask you a
question
let's start with the cutlet okay a
beautiful
let's start with the come on joe enough
with the nonsense okay
a beautiful golden brown juicy love with
the nonsense
no you said that yeah i am
because you when you get me heated i
stumble over my i get you heated yeah
you get me
okay you got me heated like nobody else
all right if there's only a few people
that get me heated
who's the other some of them are
terrorists like you're in that camp
i've had enough all right you know what
i'm saying i don't appreciate a couple
things one of them terrorism the other
is your [ __ ]
okay you you you you make a beautiful
cutlet
the way it's supposed to be made just
perfectly the perfect amount of of
of thickness it's golden brown crispy
juicy it's succulent it's just it's just
moist and delicious you put that on a
beautiful semolina bread toasted
maybe a little flowers on there little
sesame seed you toast the bread a little
bit
and you put just a beautiful delicious
sweet sauce on there a red sauce
got a little substance too it's got a
little like a little chunky sauce right
on that and you melt
just a just a soft beautiful mozzarella
over that
and okay the the cheese is melting at
just the right amount
and it's got the sauce trapped under it
and then and the chicken cutlet
is still crispy and it's warm and juicy
and the bread is just like the
just a kiss at the end that brings all
together the sandwich comes together
like no
other it's it's the king of the pizzeria
sandwich no and the pizza pizza
is the king of the pizzeria sandwiches
oh god now let me do what you just said
just too much something let me do what
you just did oh there's something you
you just did when you get some nice iron
beef and you slice it perfectly thin
and there's just the right amount of
marbling in it and you put it on that
flat top
and you fry it out with just the right
amount of salt and pepper to season it
steak
and you bring in you bring in honey
i didn't do this to you a chicken palm
hero
you're naming st no that's not what i
said that's not you listen closely
you'll hear people all across the world
passing out i didn't do this to you
i wouldn't describe you right now just
shut it off i just shut it off i'll let
you describe your thing can i describe
my thing
yeah just the right amount of marbling
in that quality shut up
going to grandma's house this sunday for
our famous italian cheese oh yeah
because i know
she's going to use cheese whiskey every
weekend peppers i know everyone's
talking to your horses yeah i know every
weekend my nana would say come over for
sunday dinner
i'm going to put chicken fingers on a
roll
and duck and ragu on it listen
let me finish my description let me
finish my description let me finish my
description
i'm not speaking no you are actually
you're doing the opportunity let me
finish my description uninterrupted
thrice no no no
because you keep talking and
interrupting am i
crazy he's talking he's pimp agrees pimp
the air you're talking you're talking
now he's not you now he's not your
child that you scold now you're not
talking i see you see the dynamic that's
going on here cut
your mouth you're in a mood today boy
i'm not you're in a movie today you're
an idiot you put me in a movie no
i put you in a movie you arrived in the
mood oh stop yeah
okay i right you're pleasant as a pizza
oh really because that's the words i
would never use to describe
you even on your best day can i finish
this mistake
description can i finish my cheesesteak
description
you mean the italian iron beef that it's
just beautifully sliced it's got the
right amount of marbling in it to give
it the right amount of flavor
okay okay shut up
you get a sweet vidalia onion or yellow
onion you dice it
you get that sweet flavor coming out you
mix that onion into the meat
you you mix
you mix the cheese in it
why
and then you put it on a perfectly
crusty hard on the outside salt to the
inside you know what you do
especially in these debates you're a car
if i could liken you to this
your car that's on the highway going
like 75 you're going like 20 above the
speed limit
and you are swerving all over the place
not using a blinker you're really
not and then someone like me a voice of
reason possibly a patrolman will pull
you over
and then you say is there a problem
officer like you were just staying in
the middle lane
like you were just driving in the middle
lane the whole time like there was no
issues you
swerve all over the place and then let
me let you get away without describing
my sandwich the way you're describing
your sandwich i'm telling you when it's
great it's great
take all the ingredients here's my point
what's the ingredients here's my point
st steak which is better than chicken or
a
that's not fair sliced steak steak is
better than chicken
steak not a steak not like a steak not
like a t-bone or a tomato
the same thing it's just a slice thin
steak
it's the least best part of the steak
like cheesesteaks have their own
restaurant come on the chicken parm
doesn't stand a chance
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard in my life i don't even want
blackberries it disagrees with you just
block her
i can't take people i will say this if
you're gonna comment
use some comments closing i will cheese
have their own
they do all over the place there's no
parmesan restaurant except
parm in the east village which is great
which is great
that's why it's a gimmick though philly
cheesesteaks are the perfect example of
philly
nasty in just a minute thank you thank
you
cheesecake and i'm like okay is that an
onion is that a grease is that
cheese mixed with grease what is this
gross thing that's
argument and then you can see closing
you didn't even let me
no are you nuts my closing argument is
this
steak what's a better first bite let me
just give my closing argument without
interruption steak
better than chicken less wrong
now let me give the argument steak
better than chicken
less bread better than more bread option
of sauce
it's good with or without it okay
and finally cheese choices
multiple not restricted to one
sandwich mozzarella is let's go let's go
item for item you said sliced
steak is better than a golden brown it's
better than chicken yeah
that's what i said the steak in a cheese
steak is sliced steak it's the it's the
lower ends part of a steak
is better that's better than a golden
brown
a chicken breast a chicken cutlet yes
i think a golden brown hot crispy
chicken cutlet is better than
sliced chopped steak that's what i
believe i also believe that
italian mozzarella cheese is better than
cheese whiz
or yellow american it's white american i
keep it
right american that's your favorite
version of salmon provolone
all right i think mozzarella is better
than all those cheeses i'm not
it's a sandwich chicken parm all the way
we're reading the comments and honestly
what do you have that goes up against
are
the
sauce
on a cheese steak mushroom you can put
pepperoni on a chicken which is amazing
what do you have that goes up against
sauce the chicken is better than the
spice
it goes on the steak it's a pizza steak
it's a cheese steak
you put the sauce on i don't want a
pizza steak version of a cheesecake
mozzarella
cheese and sauce and that's a pizza
steak what are you talking about
i can't believe at the end of it you're
going to throw in pizza steaks
it's a traditional cheese steak and a
chicken parm hero
i got news for you a pizza steak is one
of the original
traditional cheese i'm sorry buddy oh my
god she's making
no contact well doing this she said i
can't believe she's still doing this
sauce is mine in this argument
you have no faith in anything you have
no integrity you have no
idea you cannot say cheese stickers
chicken parm and then go well i'll put
red sauce on my cheese and make it an
italian cheese steak
and i'll take your ingredients everyone
knows for the sake of this argument red
sauce
belongs to me
it's common in a cheese stick what are
you talking about
cheese sticks it's like that's like me
saying all right you know what i'll also
take chicken cullet put american cheese
lettuce tomato onion and mayo
i know that's the chicken parmesan shut
up
cheesesteak from morgan says she said no
contest contest you couldn't pay me
to pick that barbaric chicken parm even
if jesus himself came it down and made
it for me
you know what though i'll give props
when something makes sense that does not
a bad cheesesteak is better than any
chicken farm sandwich chicken plums or
cheese sticks all the way no way if you
were to give the united states an
enema you'd stick it in cleveland ohio
but as soon as you heard someone from
philly talk about how good that cheese
sandwich
you'd shove the end of a two down their
throat no but the cheesesteak is great
turns it back around to the cheesesteak
i have to say chicken parm at least when
i order
that i won't get bitched without knowing
how to order and fill
okay i was all part of my argument joey
thinks he knows everything
about sandwiches and watch him lose
that stung the cheesesteak
the cheesesteak would whiz all over the
chicken farm hero see what i did now
that's a great point
i would never do that not even to serve
my argument self-centeredly like you
just did
okay just joe just make it this is the
thing your food is never enough for you
don't stop reading
your food your food
it's an italian version of a cheesesteak
that's nice i think you can
say that just take the cheese it comes
[Music]
you're saying everything wrong if you go
to pat's steak in philly
marinara sauce is an option mushrooms
are an option
these are the basic ingredients of a
cheesesteak it's what you want or what
you don't want
the cheesecake is so strong it can
survive just the meat and cheese never
mind if you want to add these other
things it's amazing
if the chicken parm loses one of its
ingredients it sucks
that's it no because the chicken parm is
one thing it's chicken sauce mozzarella
and bread and that's it and i'm not
trying to throw any tricks any smoking
mirrors anywhere that's what it is in
the beginning of this he goes
that's wrong peppers are not cheesy
steak
it's just onions blah blah and now
you're like you could do whatever you
want with it
say that these are the basic ingredients
you were like
no people put bell peppers in israel you
didn't say bell peppers there's an
option if people like bubbles no because
they're not an option peppers are not an
option oh really
it just happens to be an everywhere
where everybody does it wrong
yeah yeah yeah everybody does everything
wrong all the time and you're dumb
i really i'm going to read today's
comments okay
i want to see we need to pick a winner
they have to pick a part where you did
hit we need to pick a winner let's do it
well that's what i was trying to do ah
yes cheesecake the most
cheesesteak the most inconsistent of all
sandwiches everywhere you go it's
different
so in this case chicken porn wins hands
down joe they don't hear us
these are people that are echoing my
sentiments without even hearing me
chicken parm zero cheesesteak all day
every day
that's a funny thing to say the cheese
steak sandwiches win over chicken
sandwiches for me nothing beats red meat
and good cheese on a bun
for the win that is the win compliment
because he said exactly what i just said
he said exactly chicken parm is the food
equivalent of returning home after a
long trip
cheese stick is taking the wrong
accident gary indiana all right that's
the winner
that one wins that's a funny that's the
funniest tweet give him give him the win
give him the win
let's see who's gonna be really
interesting i don't know who's gonna win
this do you
no i honestly don't i'm curious i oh my
god i think cheesesteak will be more
popular countrywide
nine thousand votes votes really low
today
i don't know why anyway well we did a
hundred thousand on the first one
anyway all right
[Music]
luke 64.1
for the cheesesteak for the cheesesteak
35.9
for the stupid dumb sandwich you picked
[Laughter]
64 oh that's a beautiful landslide
that's a beautiful landslide you know
what folks
how is that possible check me out on
jodarosa comedy on instagram and twitter
uh and check out my other podcast if you
want to hear my salient arguments
uh we'll see you in hell you can get new
episodes at patreon.com w-y-w-s-y-i-h
podcast dot
uh christ almighty patreon.com
wsyihpodcast uh and
uh the back catalog wherever you get
your audio podcast savilecanocomedy.com
for all my tour dates uh i'll be uh
announcing a solo tour soon and then
the guys and i from the show are doing a
tour uh text me on the community app
718-260-6619
uh i try to text people back there um
this was a fan episode so thank you to
the fans for giving us this match-up uh
this was a sobering defeat from me
uh i think it's the fact that in between
the goal posts or the coasts i think
cheesesteak is just a more prominent
sandwich i don't think it's
because the cheesesteak is a better
sandwich because it just outright isn't
it
excuses and you're lost leave with
dignity what else what else
check out the no press pack of saratoga
peanut butter at yo peanut.com
we've got a taste buds flavor and we got
a hey babe flavor goes to the chair it
goes to charity
and uh that's it i still love you baby i
love you too
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds